[Applause]
foreign
they like me they really like me
what it is I'm Tyrus and I'm in for the
little guy Gutfeld
it's he is a little guy because the
lights are like burning me in the eyes
because they're adjusted for someone who
sees like this so you gotta
and I got spots
and it's the worst day to have spots
because today is a big day this is a big
show cat this is our two-year
anniversary show
yeah well uh this marriage of the three
of us isn't off to a great start with
Greg forgetting it's our anniversary
yeah and running off to Germany to make
art films like he's Lord farqua
[Music]
look at that yeah you see it
yep
not by bloop
Waze thanks for nothing Greg no but
thank you Greg cat staff team and our
amazing fans for making us number one
and let's not forget Gene who does all
the dancing and singing and annoying
things
but we will not put the camera on him
not even for a second
mwah
that sounded like Greg all right now to
the monologue so if a coward dies a
thousand deaths and a soldier dies but
once how many times do they get to
attempt to end them
in the case of what's of those going
after president Donald Trump apparently
they need two impeachments one fake
Dozier two years of Russian collusion
umpteen bias news networks special
counsels and now 34 yes 34 counts of the
same crime
while they're at it why not throw in
some new charges on the table about how
about attempting to build a wall without
a permit
let's write him a citation for tweeting
after midnight
heck I'm pretty sure he Framed Roger
Rabbit haha
or how about referring to himself as the
big guy and using his son and his
brother and business associates to take
money from China and Ukraine
oh wait no that's I got confused that's
the current Administration my bad
but I figured if you're going to make it
up let's go full regalia
[Applause]
you know kind of like Alvin Beck I mean
Bragg is doing
after the arraignment he refused to put
a bow on it and specify the the basis
for the indictment when asked why he
said because I don't have to
I don't have to
that's what a whiny four-year-old says
when you want ask them to eat their
vegetables I don't have to I mean did he
stick his tongue out and Skip away
afterwards
anyways let's talk about the most
hilarious thing that happened yesterday
just hours after president Trump was
arraigned a federal appeals court
ordered Stormy Daniels to pay him I'm
gonna say it again to pay him over 120
Grand in legal fees
and knowing stormy she'll probably have
to pay all crumpled up one dollar bills
it's money it's still good
you never bought stuff when grandma gave
you the jar of coins come on man
well hopefully he didn't go to the strip
club with it
all right
it was all it was all over a 2018
defamation suit she filed against him
that later was dismissed so let me see
if I can understand while he's getting
arrested for 34th of the same things and
fingerprinted somehow somehow he was
still winning
this dude made money going to jail
let's think about that for a second you
not just money he made over a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars
most of us are looking for money or
relatives are money when we get arrested
this dude's making money so I think
there's hope for us all with that then
if it's not cool enough he hops on a
flight back to Mar-A-Lago and takes the
mic for a half an hour and everyone
Tunes in even Lil Wayne was like damn
okay that's impressive
it's true and during the speech Trump
cut right to it first he ripped the New
York D.A Alvin Bragg granted he's a
pretty big Target
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it the
criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive
amounts of grand jury information for
which he should be prosecuted
or at a minimum he should resign
I haven't seen tables turn that fast
since Greg spilled his soup and fell off
his booster seat
he used you were there
then Trump kindly pointed out what
pretty much everyone's been saying about
the whole case
virtually everybody that has looked at
this case including rhinos and even
hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime
and that it should never have been
brought
never have been born even people that
aren't big fans have said it they said
this is not the right thing to do
it's an insult to our country as the
world is already laughing at us for so
many other reasons
well one of those reasons might they
might be laughing at us is because of
this
let's get started Mr fetterman we're
going to begin with you what qualifies
you to be a U.S senator you have 60
Seconds
hi good night everybody
[Laughter]
[Applause]
can we do that here all right good night
[Laughter]
killed it Jamie
but Trump's right even CNN's like yeah
there's not much there but don't worry
we'll be there
in terms of a case that's being brought
against a former president it's a little
underwhelming there's not an incredible
new set of facts that we didn't know
about publicly if this is the only
Pebble that gets thrown at Donald Trump
uh it's a very small pebble this is even
weaker than I feared it would be and I I
think it's it's easily subject to being
dismissed or a quick acquittal for Trump
to sum it up this case is looking weaker
than Canada bowling alley a bodybuilders
bowling alley
because Trump basically gave his own
State of the Union Address he touched on
the economy and the inflation the war in
Ukraine China and of course Biden
if you took the five worst Presidents in
the history of the United States
and added them up
they would not have done near the
destruction to our country as Joe Biden
and the Biden Administration have done
so for the record he's saying top five
worst Presidents of all time Biden Biden
Biden Biden and Dylon and if you didn't
watch MTV I'm not going to help you
I wonder what Joe thought of all that
no no no I'm not going to comment on any
of that come on
come on I don't care about your
monologue Mr King of late night
Greg Gutfeld I'll Take You Down
I took down corn pop and I'll take you
to why do you have the guts come say
that to my face right all right Mr Greg
Gutfeld what's that
oh well who's who's guest hosting
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right let's welcome tonight's guest
she's something you rarely see these
days a skilled White House Press
Secretary co-host of outnumberton and
the author of the new book Serenity in
the storm Kaylee mcaney
[Applause]
his kids don't blame him for the divorce
they just blame him for his ACT
or Ryder comedian friend of mine Jamie
lislow
[Applause]
his idea for banks to give away free
lollipops host of making money on Fox
Business the baddest suit game there is
Mr Charles Payne
[Applause]
her resume now includes author TV star
and Boston Market cashier Fox News
contributor Kat timpf
[Applause]
Kaylee just because you were the last
Press Secretary of knowledge uh
if you were dealing with this right now
how would you be handling it would you
the the not responding from the White
House to something of this magnitude is
grossly inappropriate I feel I think it
is super smart and here's why so
Democrats are apparently gleeful right
now uh Dem strategists are love Joe
Biden in the White House versus the
leading Republican being indicted
they're loving the contrast so much that
Joe has pushed back his announcement
date because he wants Republicans to
totally and completely implode uh while
he governs so I think it's super smart
not to respond conveniently when did
Kareen Jean-Pierre announce her briefing
1 30 p.m the same time Trump is on his
way to the courthouse but Trump can get
above this he needs to beat the left at
their game and say you want to focus on
me but I'm going to focus on you the
American people I'm not going to be
distracted I'm going to tell you about
the greatest economy ever created in the
history of man under me in my presidency
and the five-time worst president of all
time Joe Biden draw that contrast you
beat the left of their game
well speaking of game
Mr Payne you've done it again I'm even
in the tennis shoes I mean the reason
why I don't wear suits to work because
you just if you can't go 10 you just
can't go at all
from an economic standpoint when we have
all this inner fighting and division at
the upper echelons of our government
does it have a trickle-down effect are
we going to see that in the stock
markets uh we're definitely saying that
sort of tourmal in the markets we're
seeing it in sentiment readings all
kinds of sentiment readings there's a
really the the disbelief or lack of uh
faith in our institutions has crumbled
big time and it's crumbling him in a lot
more I will say this about you know this
this whole Fiasco or the charade with
President Trump it's been a rocket
booster I mean what a CNN poll 76 76
percent and a CNN poll said it was
political I mean this is like I don't
know who was the architect of this thing
because I don't believe Alvin Brad came
up with it by himself no someone had to
check off on this thing right they like
yeah go ahead he's like you sure yeah go
ahead so whoever told him this was a
smart idea it is already backfired
miserably and somebody is sitting around
second guessing what do we do we have
actually made made president Trump
heroic to apolitical people you know not
people who follow this closely who watch
all the networks but just that's what
you can casually watch say this is this
is nuts this is who would want this to
happen if this happened to someone in
your family if someone in your family
was railroaded by the government we have
a bit we would all be outraged and I
think I think it's backfired miserably
on them and and all of these things are
conspiring as our economy heads rapidly
towards recession the next the next 12
months will be really tough for this
Administration
cat Charles kind of hit on a point do
you think they're going to make
president Trump the first living
breathing martyr
because that's kind of where this is
going I mean they're trying everything
yeah see people there's people who
really hate Trump in a very special way
where they've actually turned it into an
entire career and an entire identity and
even these people coming out to say this
doesn't make any sense this is going to
be dismissed or this is going to be an
easy acquittal means that they're having
to go against their identity and the
careers that we've made I mean when's
the last time we heard anything from Jeb
Bush like guys
I missed that no I was like oh yeah that
guy like
he's awoken from his sleep to say this
of all of the things and you know Trump
is somebody who's rich Trump is somebody
who's famous he's been the president of
the United States
all these unique accolades and now
they're kind of also giving him the
power of being a victim on top of all of
this because it's just so weak that even
the people who hate him so much it runs
through their veins have to say uh this
is this is this is really not going to
happen this way I just think it's it's
obviously not going to fly everybody
knows it and he's you know he's got to
be kind of happy about the way that it's
all worked out shocked probably even
shocked but how fun is Trump come on you
guy how much entertaining I just loved
how my favorite thing about the speech
was where he said my biggest crime was
and then he said some awesome he did
yeah it's like loving you too much yes
my biggest crime is I loved each and
every one of you yes too much Johnny in
the first row yeah spin song in the
third row like yeah isn't it like when
you're in an interview and they go
what's your biggest weakness and you go
having too many strengths
people hate that I have so many strong
yeah I don't like to get paid money I
work too many hours
um
I saw I saw the craziness outside New
York today if you walked around I
thought I saw Trump and his like the
whole you know all the cars and it
turned out uh Brian stelter just ordered
from ubereats and they were sure
it's never over do you know that um you
know Biden thought he was getting
arrested once I yeah I guess they were
they were like sir we need you to please
step out of the car and he was like oh
my God am I arrested and they're like no
you're home we do this every day
this is your house
because you know what
what in that same smile every time
something they ask him something that's
bad that's happened it's the same
oh yeah all the teeth showing what time
is it it's like that emoji yeah it's
like I don't think and we're giving him
too much credit you know we're like hey
he's being a smart ass and he's smiling
no that's the like I'm lost smile and
don't want to admit it to my wife like
no you're I couldn't agree more I really
for real lost faith in but when he
started the shaking hands of people that
left a while ago you know like he would
still shake hands I was like is he
crossing over can he see ghosts
is it like good to see you Grandma we'll
see you soon how is it up there
um
[Laughter]
it's just a theory I just remembered my
question okay all right before we go
like come see me live I'll be in Houston
April 23rd Walhalla South Carolina May
4th and 5th and I'll be in Biloxi
Mississippi visit my link tree and on my
Instagram and and Twitter for tickets
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else